uh some news just in and the actor alec  baldwin has been named in a legal case  in connection with the death of  the cinematographer last year uh helena  hutchins was killed when a prop gun held  by the actor went off on the set of a  film  called rust today her husband has filed  a wrongful death lawsuit alleging that  mr baldwin and several others were  responsible for miss hutchins death  we are the lawyers for matthew and  andrews hutchins  and today we filed a wrongful death case  on their behalf  in santa fe county in new mexico  in the lawsuit as you can see  names  alec baldwin and others  who are responsible for the safety on  the set  and whose reckless behavior  in cost cutting  led to the senseless and tragic death  of helena hutchins